[Aplausos]
[Música]
todo el tiempo estamos tomando
decisiones desde que comer hasta cómo
vestirnos incluso las palabras que
usamos para expresar lo que sentimos
todo se trata de decidir decidir si
hubiera un partido de la champions o
estudiar por un examen final decidir si
comerte ese último pedazo de pastel en
la cocina o tener un cuerpazo para
cancún pero para el siguiente año porque
este año creo que ya no lo hicimos
o decidir si invitarla a salir alguien
que te gusta cada segundo de cada día
estamos tomando decisiones pero que
tanto sabemos del proceso de cómo
tomamos las decisiones hoy les vengo
hablar de ese proceso de algunos
factores que influyen en cómo tomamos
decisiones y al final unos tips para
mejorar todos estos procesos
tenemos que empezar definiendo qué es
una idea cómo es que podemos nosotros
tenerías en nuestra cabeza y cómo
tomamos decisiones la verdad es que
nadie sabe en serio nadie sabe sin
embargo hay teorías intentando explicar
estas preguntas y una de las teorías más
importantes la propone david eagleman
que es un profesor de la universidad de
stanford y él ahí en su laboratorio
analiza las descargas de las neuronas
cada vez que se les presenta una
decisión
y el analizando estás despolarización es
neurales intenta definir estas preguntas
david dice que una idea es la activación
de neuronas en un orden específico
a esto él le dice que es un circuito
neural entonces cada vez que se nos
viene una idea a la cabeza es que se
están activando ciertas neuronas en un
orden ya predeterminado
entonces si una idea es un bonche
neuronas activándose en una secuencia
que es una decisión es más de un
circuito neural activándose al mismo
tiempo y cual vamos a decidir las
neuronas que se activen con mayor
intensidad les pongo un ejemplo te
levantas o en la mañana tienes demasiada
hambre
caminas todo morro hacia el refri abre
la puerta y ve lo necesario para hacerte
unas quesadillas un huevito con cartón
entonces por afuera el proceso de dar de
tomar una decisión parece muy simple
tal vez gira la cabeza un poco y al
final levantar la mano y escoger las
quesadillas no y eso es lo que te
preparas para desayunar sin embargo
dentro de nuestra cabeza es un proceso
mucho más caótico está pasando una
guerra las neuronas que representan las
ideas de las que sea ellas están
intentando o se están emitiendo señales
eléctricas las neuronas que representan
las ideas de el huevo también se estan
despolarizado entonces cada una quiere
sobresalir cada una necesita gastar
energía internalizar glucosa entonces
están des polarizando y están emitiendo
señales eléctricas y en esta pelea que
dura milisegundos al final sólo hay una
ganadora las quesadillas y eso es lo que
decides para para desayunar
entonces este proceso es un proceso que
gasta demasiada energía la pregunta aquí
es usamos este proceso para tomar todas
las decisiones que hacemos en nuestra
vida no exactamente este proceso solo lo
usamos en las decisiones conscientes
entonces durante el proceso evolutivo el
cerebro se dio cuenta de que no
necesitaba estar consciente para todas
las decisiones que tomamos la gran parte
de las decisiones que tomamos todos los
días son las mismas que tomamos todos
los días pestaña moss respiramos nos
movemos pero no lo hacemos de una manera
consciente el cerebro no tiene que pasar
por ese esa batalla interna cada vez que
toma una decisión
entonces el cerebro lo que hace se da
cuenta de las actividades o de las
decisiones que tomas todos los días y
las graba como en un disco duro para que
tú puedas entrar a ese programa sin
batallar tanto y ejercer una función
casi sin pensarlo hacerlo de manera
natural regresamos al ejemplo de
movernos de caminar cuando nosotros
estamos chiquitos claro que nos teníamos
que esforzar para mover una pierna la
pierna derecha como en la pierna
izquierda balancear nos cuida con las
cosas que hay en el camino pero una vez
que descubrimos el secreto de cómo
caminar bien
lo grabamos en el disco duro y lo
pasamos lo cambiamos de una decisión
consciente a una decisión inconsciente
y estas decisiones inconscientes aunque
nos ayudan a ahorrar energía del cerebro
ya poder nosotros tener nuestra
conciencia en otras decisiones que
tenemos que tomar diariamente tiene un
costo muy muy grande que es cuando no
estamos tomando decisiones conscientes
somos muy susceptibles a factores
externos que influyen en cómo tomamos
decisiones
entonces estoy seguro de que han
escuchado alguna vez el experimento de
pablo pablo ver a un psicólogo burro era
un psicólogo ruso que tenía una campana
y tenía un perro entonces cada vez que
pablo sonaba la campana le daba de comer
al perro sonaba la campana le da de
comer al perro sonar la campana
y comida
entonces lo hizo tantas veces que el
perro empezó a asociar la idea de la
campana con que iba a recibir comida y
la siguiente vez que para blog sonó la
campana que pasó el perro pensó que iba
a recibir comida y empezó a salivar
aunque no le dieron comida a este
fenómeno se le llama como
acondicionamiento que es que después de
un periodo de acondicionado cierto
estímulo va licitar una respuesta
específica les quiero poner un corto
vídeo de uno de mis series favoritas
explicando mejor este proceso
[Música]
efe
auto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoy neón
para nada
pero son
no
ok entonces white fue víctima de un
proceso de acondicionamiento o sea él
aunque tomó la decisión voluntaria de
levantar la mano cuando escuchó el
sonido de la computadora apagándose fue
una decisión que estuvo influenciada
inconscientemente por jim
entonces la pregunta qué interesante es
nosotros somos susceptibles a este
proceso de acondicionamiento
puede que nosotros seamos susceptibles
a pensar de manera diferente o tomar
decisiones diferentes en base a factores
externos yo creo que sí si definimos que
el conocimiento viene de fuera del
exterior nosotros por medio nuestro
sentimos de nuestros sentidos
internalizamos este conocimiento
nosotros lo analizamos nosotros lo
convertimos en datos y nosotros tomamos
decisiones en base a este conocimiento
que vino el exterior entonces podemos
decir que el factor principal que
influye en cómo tomamos decisiones es el
medio en donde vivimos en nuestra
sociedad
entonces hasta qué punto la sociedad en
la que vivimos influye en cómo tomamos
decisiones les quiero poner un ejemplo
imaginémonos una sociedad que nos dice
que a lo que le tenemos que tirar en la
vida es a ser exitosos
imaginémonos una sociedad que nos dice
que si no eres feliz que la única manera
de ser feliz es llegando ser exitoso y
que no se asocia a la idea de ser
exitosos con tener mucho dinero status
social importante con tener una casa
grande autos de lujo poder viajar a
donde ya cuando quieras entonces qué va
a pasar que vas a tener a toda una
sociedad buscando esta idea tal vez
errónea de lo que es el éxito
y este acondicionamiento social surge de
dos procesos principales el primero es
la automatización de las decisiones y el
segundo es que no nos cuestionamos lo
que pensamos y lo que hacemos
y verdaderamente nos preguntamos lo que
pensamos y lo que hacemos osea yo les
pregunto a ustedes verdaderamente si
quieren casar
verdaderamente quieren tener hijos
verdaderamente quieren empezar una
empresa y ser emprendedores como todos
los demás
yo creo que estas y muchas otras
decisiones las tomamos inconscientemente
las tomamos el nuevo automático porque
es lo que sigue porque es lo que viene
porque lo que todos hacen y es justo
esto lo que nos tenemos que plantear el
que tenemos que revisar estas decisiones
importantes en la vida de un plano
inconsciente a un plano consciente no
vivir en automático nosotros
preguntarnos entonces quién maneja y la
respuesta tiene que ser nosotros
y para esto les quiero dar tips para
mejorar su proceso de toma de decisiones
el primero es empezar por él porque el
por qué hacemos las cosas porque
queremos esto porque pensamos esto otro
porque si empezamos por él porque nos
estamos asegurando que las decisiones
que nosotros tomamos son las decisiones
que nosotros queremos
hagan meditación 510 minutos en las
noches después de un día largo que sirva
como un proceso de retroalimentación
donde se pongan a pensar lo que hicieron
bien lo que hicieron mal las decisiones
que tomaron por qué reaccionaron de
cierta manera ante alguna situación esto
les va a servir para tomar mejores
decisiones el día siguiente
la tercera nunca dejen de aprender
siempre lo escuchamos lean más oye
escucha este podcast pero porque lo
hacemos claro que el conocimiento en sí
mismo es muy importante pero yo creo que
todavía más valioso es el contraste que
nosotros le podemos dar a esa nueva
información con la información que ya
tenemos el aprender que lo que piensan
otras culturas otras ideologías el
platicar con personas con pensamientos
diferentes no debatir no argumentar ser
empáticos intentar aprender porque esas
personas piensan de esa manera y en base
a lo que tú ya conoces poder contrastar
con las demás opiniones y tú mismo sacar
tus propias conclusiones ya esto con
esto voy a mi cuarto punto el ser más
crítico es vivimos una sociedad nos da
información de todos lados estamos todo
el tiempo conectados y no está llegando
información a cada momento y es difícil
decir que gran parte de la información
que nos llega puede que no sea verdad
entonces si aceptamos información la
psila internalizamos sin analizarla
somos mucho más susceptibles a estos
acondicionamientos sociales tenemos que
ser críticos con todo lo que nos llega
con todo
y lo último y último tipo es el más
importante pero el más difícil todos es
ser humildes es difícil reconocer que lo
que yo pienso y lo que yo hago tal vez
está mal y es difícil es difícil
reconocer esos errores en uno mismo
pero sin esta
todos los demás no importan no me van a
servir en nada porque si no existe la
humildad en uno mismo el reconocer
nuestros errores no eres espacio para
crecer y si no existe ese espacio para
crecer no habrá espacio para cambiar
que ganamos con todo esto que ganamos
con todo esto que ganamos con tomar
decisiones más conscientes que ganamos
con este proceso de toma de decisiones
yo creo para mí lo más importante es la
tranquilidad esa paz interior de saber
que mis decisiones son mías intentar
minimizar el acondicionamiento social
porque así me aseguro que es lo que yo
quiero y no lo que los demás quieren de
mí
entonces yo quiero que cada vez que
suene esta campana
piensen en las decisiones que están
tomando todos los días quiero que cada
vez que suene la campana vuelvan a mover
esas decisiones de un plan inconsciente
a un plano consciente porque es la única
manera de saber lo que ustedes quieren y
yo quiero que cada vez que toque esta
campana ustedes piensen en quiénes son
en que quieren y cómo pueden mejorar
muchísimas gracias